we have a very special program for you
this evening and not one but three very
fine authors all journalists all
seasoned intrepid war reporters they've
written memoirs and are here to discuss
their experiences in Afghanistan Syria
and other conflict zones first at the at
the far my far right is Janine de
Giovanni Newsweek's Middle East editor
and a contributing editor at Vanity Fair
at the start of her journalistic career
Janine covered the first Palestinian
Intifada in the late 1990s since then in
the 1980s
I had 1980 so I don't know why I said
1990s since then she's reported on
turmoil and civil conflicts throughout
the Middle East and Beyond in her latest
book the morning they came for us
she chronicles the war in Syria using
seven different perspectives she
provides a vivid picture of a ravaged
nation has experienced by its citizens
among them a nun a doctor a musician and
a student their stories convey the
realities of modern urban warfare from
the pervasive smoke to the hunger to the
return of such previously vanquished
diseases as typhus and polio next to
Janine is Christina lamb currently the
chief foreign correspondent for The
Sunday Times like Janine Christina's
introduction to conflict reporting also
came in the late 1980s but in Pakistan
and Afghanistan her journalism has since
taken her far and wide including
assignments in Brazil South Africa
Zimbabwe and Iraq but since the 9/11
attacks she's spent quite a bit of time
in F in Afghanistan she wrote I am
Malala or co-wrote I am Malala with
Nobel Peace Prize winner Malala
yousufzai and her new book
farewell Kabul highlights the errors and
miscalculations
made by the United States and his allies
in the war in Afghanistan and and argues
that the world has been left more not
less dangerous since 9/11 our third
author is a Kim Barker whose book the
Taliban shuffle about her reporting in
Afghanistan and Pakistan
served as the basis for the recent movie
Wisco and whiskey-tango-foxtrot starring
Tina Fey Kim's first reporting jobs were
with papers in Indiana and Washington
State after joining the Chicago Tribune
in 2001 she ended up going abroad and
spent five years from 2004 to 2009 as
the Trib South Asia bureau chief based
in New Delhi and Islamabad she now
writes for The New York Times a Times
review of her book called it both
hilarious and harrowing two contrasting
adjectives that also sum up the
frequently mixed experience of war
reporting moderating discussion by by
this impressive group of panelists will
be married jordan herself a Pulitzer
Prize winning journalist with the
Washington Post Mary was based abroad
for for 14 years in Tokyo Mexico City in
London and she's currently covering the
presidential campaign
you need you need that foreign
experience she-she-she told me as we
were walking in that she just
interviewed Donald Trump today so you
might want to ask her about that anyway
we're sort of getting off track aren't
we
Mary's most recent book which she
co-wrote with her husband Kevin Sullivan
also of the Washington Post is titled
hope a memoir of survival in Cleveland
in chronicle the kidnapping and torment
of two of the women held captive in a
home in Cleveland by Ariel Castro so
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming our panel
[Applause]
[Music]
well I really feel like I'm having
dinner at three different five-star
restaurants tonight you know this is
it's impossible to do justice to the
careers of these three women but we're
sure gonna have fun trying and I see in
the audience
they'll covet great news men of our time
and it's a testament to this working
it's a testament to all the work that
you've done so I would ask first before
we get into other things how did this
happen
you know other kids grow up and they
want to be they want to run Facebook
yeah well I never wanted to be a
journalist I was an academic and I was
doing my master's degree when in
comparative literature in Russian and
French literature so completely
different and I wanted to be a professor
and write novels possibly and write
literary criticism and one day I saw a
photograph of an Israeli soldier burying
a Palestinian teenager alive with a
bulldozer of sand and the article was
about a human rights lawyer called
Felicia Langer who was a Jewish
Holocaust survivor who was one of the
few Israeli lawyers than defending
Palestinians in military court and it
was Providence I flew to Israel I met
her she took me under her wing and I
feel like I went through a door that
never I could never go back again and I
basically couldn't finish my PhD I am I
she said to me if you have the ability
to give a voice to people that do not
have a voice then you have an obligation
and I was just wanted by injustice and
that I could as a journalist have some
kind of impact by doing this and then
the war in Bosnia came and that was a
whole other that opened a whole other
scenario for my colleagues and I
no amazing no I mean I also never set
out to be a war correspondent I always
wants to write I loved writing and I
wanted to have adventures but basically
I became a war correspondent as a result
of an invitation to a wedding and what
happened was I started after I left
University I worked as an intern at the
Financial Times in London and one day
the foreign editor was supposed to be
going to a lunch of South Asian
politicians and last minute he couldn't
go and he said to me you're always going
on about India why don't you go to this
lunch so I went to the lunch sat next to
somebody who is secretary general for
the Pakistan Peoples Party which was
Benazir Bhutto's party and he asked me
if I'd like to interview Benazir who was
living in London in exile at the time so
of course I said yes and the day that I
went to interview her was the day that
she announced her engagement as if ali
zardari
so the apartment was full of bouquets of
flowers and we got on very well she was
very good at charming foreign
correspondents particularly men I think
that she then went back to Pakistan I
went to work as a trainee for a British
regional TV company whereas the most
junior person and was doing kind of
flower shapes and things like that
and one day came home from work and
there was this absolutely beautiful
golden scribed invitation on my doormat
and it was to venice's wedding in
Pakistan so of course I went and I it
was just the most amazing introduction
to Pakistan it was like something out of
Arabian Nights them if you've ever been
to a South Asian wedding they go on for
very long time they're very colorful and
each evening after the ceremonial events
there were discussions about how to take
on Pakistan's military dictator General
Zia and all of her colleagues were
people who had
tear gassed and tortured and imprisoned
and the most dangerous thing I'd ever
had to deal with was finding my way home
after missing the last train in London
so it was fascinated so I came back to
London and said I'm gonna go and live in
Pakistan and everybody I went to talk to
all of the foreign editors said we're
not interested in Pakistan general Xia's
been there for years nothing's going to
change but we are interested in
Afghanistan because the Russians are
there so why don't you go and cover that
so being 21 at the time I agreed and the
last story I ever did for British
television was a man who turned his car
back to France it looked like it was
going forwards when it was going
backwards I don't think I was great loss
to British TV wedding so we'll go back
to the Israeli because you would then
went on to many other places but Kim
tell us how you your story is equally
different from these two about how you
got in ever since I took a journalism
class when I was a sophomore in Laramie
Wyoming and I thought what a great con
you know the whole idea that I could get
at a class and like pull my friends out
of class and ask questions and write
about it it just seemed like the
greatest job in the world so I never
thought about being a foreign
correspondent though I was very we
didn't travel anywhere my parents I grew
up not the richest person in the world
and we never even went to Canada or
Mexico growing up we always stayed local
to Wyoming in Montana
so after 9/11 happened though I was at
the Chicago Tribune and there were other
people who were volunteering to go and
you would see like these desks sort of
empty out and you know this person would
go try it and I kind of felt like not
that I wanted to be a war correspondent
but that I wanted to see if I could
cover the biggest story in the world and
I didn't know that I would end up
falling in love with it and end up
staying for so long but I did I did
actually volunteer for the for going
overseas when I heard that they were
going to try to send some more women
overseas because we hadn't tried out a
lot of women I think at one point I went
out with a female friend and we both
wanted to go cover 9/11 and cover
everything and we counted the number of
men that had been sent out
and like the number of women and it was
like 17 men and one woman so I wanted to
also prove that a woman could do it so I
was trying to figure out how I could
distinguish myself from the other female
reporters that might volunteer when I
heard that they were looking to send
more women overseas and I don't speak
any foreign languages I hadn't even been
to Europe but I went in with the biggest
argument I had which was I introduced
myself and I said hello I'm Kim Barker
I'm a metro reporter I'm single and I'm
childless and therefore I'm expendable
yeah I did say that he laughed and I
said I'll go anywhere you want to send
me send me and he was just like get
ready to go to Pakistan and I called my
parents after that and I said I'm going
to Pakistan and they said well no no
you're not why on earth would anybody
send you to Pakistan turns out they were
wrong so and then I went four months
later when I got posted first to Tokyo I
called my mother and it was a big deal I
mean at the time in the 90s it was and
my mom goes oh no what did you do wrong
at work but let me read you something
that Kim wrote in her book and you'll
get a flavor for how she writes
Afghanistan felt more like home than
anywhere else in the region I knew why
Afghanistan sounded seemed familiar
it had jagged blue and purple mountains
big skies and bearded men and pickup
trucks stocked with guns and hate for
the government
it was like Montana just on different
drugs so let's go back to you for a
second Kim and you know it is you have
at one point she's talking in the book
the the phone rings OH the Taliban
always calls it the wrong time how do
you balance kind of beheadings with
stand-up comedy this is on c-span and
like you just asked me the hardest
question I think I mean I think any
journalist it's just like you know when
you're a police officer an emergency
room doctor you know anybody who has to
go through trauma anybody who grows up
in Afghanistan or Pakistan you you use
dark comedy to deal with horrible things
just because you're in a war zone
just because people are being killed
doesn't mean that you stop living your
life and that people stop having these
small moments and laughter I think it's
a healer and it's a way to bring people
together and you know I just and I guess
it's also because my dad really brought
me up watching mash it was like we
didn't go to church every week we had to
watch mash and I was like I hate that
show
you know this war actually only lasted
like a couple years and the show is
lasting like 25 you know but you know it
and it's also like I read I think the
first one of the first authors I read
and I really loved was Kurt Vonnegut and
then I read Joseph Heller and I was just
I sort of like I think you know absorbed
that whole idea of dark comedy being a
good way to talk about war and to talk
about what's happened over there and I
think that really used to be a tradition
of that you know until there was no more
draft and then like once the draft
stopped it's like this whole idea that
now that everybody doesn't know somebody
who goes to war you can't make jokes you
can't talk about like how people really
live over there it's all this sort of
reverence for the idea of war and the
whole idea that everybody's fighting all
the time which is just not factual
because you you know through humor it
was like you you could picture you there
and yet you were giving us so much
information and I think
that's why the reviews have been through
the roof about your book so
congratulations of course the movie that
was just made so I have to ask so what's
Tina Fey like she's serious I think I'm
actually funnier no I'm kidding I'm
kidding Tina no Tina is really
incredibly generous I didn't spend a lot
of time with her before they ended up
filming the movie because I think there
are two kinds of actors the ones who
like to spend a lot of time with
somebody and sort of inhabit them and
then the ones that like to take a
character and make it their own almost
like you don't want to spend any time
with that person so I mean we just had a
long lunch which I just remember
complaining about high heels really I
mean we complained a lot about high
heels and then she told me a story that
I told was really funny and I was proud
of myself and I for the life of me
couldn't remember what the story was so
I told something that made Tina Fey
laugh and I don't know what it was and
then like you know when I was on set she
was really kind to me she and and during
the whole process it every single time
that she was on a late-night show she
would mention my name and my book the
original title by name and so I think my
publisher was thinking that the movie
tie-in that's got her face on the cover
and it's called whiskey-tango-foxtrot
would end up eclipsing the Taliban
shuffle because of the movie but because
she mentioned it so much the Taliban
shuffle started selling out all the time
on Amazon so I can't say enough nice
things about her she's just been
incredibly generous to me and she's very
much a supporter of women and I really
benefited from that well let's go back
you know there's it used to be that
there were not that many war
correspondents that were female but
right now the Washington Post actually
has quite a few and a lot of other
people do too and ELISA Rubin just won
the new the Pulitzer for the New York
Times covering Afghan women but it's it
is very different isn't it let's go
we'll start with Jeanine and just talk
about how being a woman in a war zone
affects reporting
there were very very few women and the
women that were in the field in my case
in the Middle East weren't very friendly
to other women I think it was because it
was so competitive
it was so mal it was so driven that
there was a great sense of competition I
think now it's radically changed but I
do think I've been asked this question
over and over again do men and women
report in different ways and I think
it's very individual because what I do
I'm a human rights reporter I go into
the field I spend a long time with
people or on a certain story I don't
I'm a terrible scoop reporter or
sensationalized reporter I'm not good at
going and getting you know the finding
the mother of the last Brit in Sierra
Leone or something like that but I need
to spend a long time and I think that
we're talking earlier about the war in
Bosnia Bosnia was the water the
watershed moment that changed reporting
in our in our generation I think it was
basically our generations Vietnam and it
was the time when a small group of us
were very very committed to affecting
policy and we felt that we were not
going to let this genocide happen on our
watch and we stuck it out we lived in
Sarajevo during the siege with the
people we were sniped we were shelled we
were starved we were we didn't have food
we didn't have water but yet we we did
something that I'm very proud of and I
feel like everyone that was in that war
and covered that war feels that it
changed their lives forever and their
style of reporting and we all felt very
very committed same thing and that's why
I want to drive Syria home right now is
it's a slow-motion genocide very similar
to Sarajevo that we were calling out
must be stopped the world must pay
attention to it now I live in Paris and
coming to America for the past two weeks
on this book tour I'm really amazed by
how little attention is getting that you
know it's it's there is there people
being slaughtered in in Aleppo last week
the hospital where I work
alkyds Hospital the only pediatrician
was killed the the first responders the
white
helmets were the incredib Ravus people
in the world
we're not the bravest people in well
they are they go out and dig people out
of the rubble five of them were killed
the gynecologist who delivers the babies
was killed in Aleppo yes I think Europe
traditionally there's more interest in
what well this is an election year for
America and I do understand that but I
also think Syria seems so remote but so
did Bosnia and then there was a genocide
of 8000 men and boys and we said it
would never happen again and and it it
is happening now because Janine's book
is it's just heroin and just like she
said she spends a lot of time with
different people and you kind of can't
indelible images of really horrible
things that that happened but back to
the question Kristen if you would pick
it up about do women bring something to
correspondence especially in war zones
that you wouldn't get if otherwise you
know there's been a lots of talk about
women are different at the peacemaking
table are they different or do they
bring something is there a reason we
need diversity in war in the war
correspondence yeah I think women and
men report quite differently more I
think that mail or reporters tend to
focus much more on the actual fighting
the bangbang if you like I've covered
war for 28 years but I tell the
difference between incoming and outgoing
unfortunately but I can't really tell
you very well what kind of weapons are
being fired well where well I focus on
of the people behind the lines the
people that are living the war because
actually when you see war on TV when you
see Syria or places on TV it looks like
you know everything is fighting when you
actually go to the countries there are
millions of people still living their
lives trying to educate their children
trying to feed them and protect them and
those generally tend to be the women so
I do think that women focus on that more
and I've spent most of my career in the
Middle East and in a lot of those
countries it's impossible for male
reporters to go into
the women's quarters so actually I'm
getting access to both sides in a way
that a lot of my male colleagues are not
my husband Kevin Sullivan spent a lot of
time in more countries and he was just
saying in some places even the coffee
shop only the women are on one side and
then on the other and of course he felt
cut off from a lot of the women so it's
clearly an upside especially in Muslim
countries to have women report his hair
what are the downsides are there
downsides Kim you know it's difficult
I'm I've never reported as a man so it's
difficult for me to sort of somehow you
could difficult for me to sit there and
say what's different but you know I'm
sure it's like there are downsides
because it you know I think when with a
personal life when you're living over
there you've got to be really careful
with what you're doing you know and
there's been like books written like
emergency sex and all this stuff
norine wanted me to talk about sex over
there right yeah yeah so and you really
couldn't live like that as a woman
because you had to be really careful
about the follow-up but there's a span
so I don't know what to do with you the
emergency part of this book it's a book
it has nothing to do with like anything
else it's something no no no it's
nothing actually that happens you don't
have to worry about it it's a book that
came out that wrote a lot about this but
no what I was saying is a woman over
there you had to be really protective of
your reputation in a way I don't think
male journalists had to you know you
always had to be careful who you're
going out with what time you were coming
home because you were working with
Afghans a lot of the times and you had
to make sure that they wanted to protect
you and so therefore I felt like you
almost had this obligation to to refute
the idea of being this Western loose
woman right and that would come up a lot
of times I mean it came up in Pakistan
it came up in India came up in
Afghanistan it comes up for all of us
where you know you're think you're just
being friendly to people and then you
start getting phone calls in the middle
of the night and you can't turn your
phone off because your editors might
call and you know they're calling during
Ramadan it's 4:00 in the morning and
it's like I love you and
you're like thanks but I need some sleep
and you couldn't turn your phone off and
so it was it's irritations like that
it's irritations of being grabbed in
public of you know you know I write a
lot about the fact that I mean I'm tall
I'm 5 foot 10 and I did punch out a lot
of guys because I just got so irritated
and I would just start punching them and
that was dangerous you know obviously
like my fixer didn't necessarily like
that because he was the guy that would
get in trouble for that and I found that
you know the grabbing happened equally
in India and Pakistan so I don't like it
when people bring religion to the punch
they didn't like it with like you know
it's funny because it's like I write
about Nawaz Sharif in the book you know
he's the current prime minister of
Pakistan buying me an iPhone and I think
all of us have had similar experiences
and after the book came out I'd have
like this guy on Twitter is like you
know this is really unprofessional Kim
because all of that hitting on the on
you stuff was probably off the record it
was off the record and am i I don't
think you're allowed to be off the
record when you're hitting on somebody I
don't I don't I think that's on the
record and I also felt like it really
you know writing about that sort of
stuff shows the level of you know I'm
gonna pretend to be the sort of very
religious man in in public but then
behind the scenes I think this is okay
to behave this way with women everyone
always says the difference between men
and women
I've always resented when when they try
to say women cover orphanages and
hospitals and men cover war because I've
done a lot of frontline stuff too I'm
not interested in guns but I have done a
lot of military work but the moment that
really changes for me personally it was
when I had a child and that just that
drew the line completely because I know
my male colleagues have children and
some of them used to say now now you're
entering the club where you're going to
read bedtime stories by satellite phone
but I do think and I'll go this is a
risk saying this that that for women
it's very different because we we carry
the try
we give birth and there was this kind of
extraordinary bond and I'll never forget
when my son was six months old
my old paper the times which is not the
most sensitive paper in the world to
women
my editor deliberately sent me back to
Iraq where I had been living for about
two years covering Saddam and the
invasion and the war and I was still
breastfeeding and I didn't want to go
and I begged them not to send me but
they used a clause in my contract to
send me and they said we've got a war
reporter that won't go to war and I said
it's it there is nowhere that says I am
a war reporter I am a correspondent I'm
a senior foreign correspondent I'm not a
war reporter send me to Paris or
Brussels or something and I went and my
foreign desk was like quite a macho
little scene and the guy who was running
the office said to me he wanted me to go
out and do something incredibly
dangerous the first day I got there and
it would have amounted to about two
lines in a story that was being fed in
from Washington and I said no and I
heard him on the phone cackling to some
of his friends going DiGiovanni lost her
nerve now that she had a baby and it was
it was so awful but it really I thought
and I remember getting on the phone and
calling my husband and crying and crying
and he said but that's a good thing
isn't it a good thing that you lost your
nerve and that you're afraid you're
supposed to be afraid you know you can't
be the last person in in the middle of
bombs flying you've got to kind of feel
like a human being after you had your
baby what change did you stop doing
certain things I I think for me it was
very personal because I very much felt
suddenly before that I had worked in
Africa for years and years and years and
I was very happy to in bed with militias
in Sierra Leone or the Ivory Coast and
and spend months and months and months
putting myself at great risk and I
suddenly got afraid like in a normal way
I didn't want to get injured you've just
been in Syria several times so I know
it's a really conflicting thing because
as he got older I realized that my
this sounds very selfish and some people
might think I'm irresponsible and I
would not be able to argue with you
about that I mean I feel that what I do
is much more of a m'ling in a sense and
I really believe in what I do and I
think it's hugely important that there
are reporters that bear witness to
atrocities and human rights violations
and without us and without our eyes and
ears on the ground we don't get a view a
window into what's happening do you know
what's happening in Aleppo right now you
know you don't and I I just felt that in
some way I had to make this breach and
it's been really hard I can't say it's
been easy it's by story by story Chris
didn't why don't you pick that up
because that happens to you all the time
all of us right you balance work and
life but if you're you know it's one
thing to bail work life family balance
when you're an insurance person in
Pittsburgh but if you're trying to
manage risk and going to just about the
world's most dangerous places which all
of you have been repeatedly how do you
balance is this story worth it you have
a son - and a family yeah I mean it's
very difficult it's I think once you're
responsible for a child and you're a
mother you have to think about that
first and so I don't go to places where
I know that I'm going to be in crazy
risk and I think one of the things you
learn about this job is actually the
most dangerous things that have ever
happened to me being ambushed or being
in suicide bombs have often been in
places which weren't supposed to be
dangerous so it's actually very
difficult to to plant this and look we
see these days you can be blown up in
Brussels in Paris in anywhere so you
know it is I think difficult sort of
balance but I definitely since I've
become a mother just sixteen years now I
am much more careful at where I go and I
think you will say that you feel a bit
differently because you meet mothers and
who are going through terrible things
whose children are being
attacked and you can identify with them
much more than when you want their
mother so and it's very hard sometimes
to live with that in war zones you know
that that that are trying to keep their
families together because they're so
impressive women trying to to raise
children in the middle of war friends at
the State Department are all skyping
from very dangerous places yesterday
their friends so miss expendable how do
you feel about danger I didn't need to
have a kid to value my life I love this
argument that you're supposed to somehow
change after you have children as if
your life's not important before that
you know and like how important is your
life it's probably the most important
thing to me
you know and like I'm parents and I also
more importantly had a fixer and a
driver and you know for me after what
happened to Alex Pondi in Afghanistan
when he was when his head was cut off
after they were cut kidnapped him in an
Italian journalists were kidnapped by
the Taliban and the the journalist was
released and left behind and Ajmal was
killed I was like yeah we don't need to
do those things if you feel like they're
dangerous Farook and there's no story I
wasn't the sort of person who's like oh
I'm gonna go out in the middle of the
countryside and meet the Taliban and
those reporters are great they're
probably better reporters than I am I
was happy to go to jail and meet the
Taliban who had just been arrested
because they had been arrested I and I
was happy to have them come to meet me
inside cities at hotels you know because
there was like a string of times where
you know friends might be I'm going to
go meet the Taliban I'm like and you're
gonna get kidnapped and it would happen
I mean there is this case-by-case thing
that we all have to deal with and it's
that's a good point and and if the story
is the same when you can talk to
somebody behind bars it's very different
but if you want to be eyewitness
since Janine is gonna talk about in a
minute sometimes you you can't just go
to as you know I think what's
interesting is that for all of you
different things triggered why you went
there
then you got there and you got hooked
and I just want to read a passage from
Christina's book that it's towards the
end of her book she it's called war
never leaves you and November 2014 in of
course in the end I went back I missed
Afghanistan with the yearning that I
could not explain
I had an adorable clapboard house in
Washington with the rocking chair on the
porch and a white picket fence where
every day a yellow school bus came to
collect my son just like in the American
movies and I had a great job and
wonderful friends yet part of me was
somewhere else entirely dreaming of
pomegranate pips shining red as rubies
if I drove through Rock Creek Park with
my roof down the scent of pines reminded
me of the mountains in pack Tia in my
big American house I had a walk-in
wardrobe its shelves piled with silk
scarves in bright colors like magenta
pink and peacock blue each one with a
memory and you went on from there about
how you had to go back because it was
just always in your senses you missed
sitting on the village floors drinking
green tea and listening to fantastical
stories of ancient feuds I never
remembered the bad bits so is it that
you write it's like is it like
childbirth you just kind of okay I mean
a lot of bad things happened you lost
friends colleagues people you knew and
yet you kept going back I think when you
keep going to the same place over and
over again it's not a story it you know
the people there you didn't think of it
as an issue it is you think about all
the people that you know there and
what's happening to them and you want
people to know about it I mean one of
the things I feel very
angry about at the moment is the way
that people is sort of accepting that
from our politicians that the war in
Afghanistan is over because we declare
it over a couple of years ago in fact
more people were killed in Afghanistan
than any year of the war and what makes
me most angry is the situation of the
women there because you remember that
when the Taliban were toppled the
discussion was now we're gonna make
women free and Laura Bush and Cherie
Blair and people gave radio dresses and
talked about it actually we encouraged
women in Afghanistan see all sorts of
things they would never otherwise done
run for office become security guards
doing all sorts of things which is good
but now we've just left those people
behind and we're not protecting them and
they stood up and have done things that
were not traditional in their culture
and now they're being targeted and we're
not there to help them and I actually I
think we have a moral responsibility to
do something about that so I feel really
passionately that we shouldn't forget
and once you're so deep in a story you
feel a responsibility let the world know
so in Janine's book she writes these
indelible images of things and it was
touched by this one passage in in
Janine's book when my son was born
shortly after the American occupation of
Iraq I was unable to cut his nails
it was visceral rather than rational
reaction I would pick up the tiny baby
scissors and look at his translucent
fingers clean and pink as seashells and
feel as though I would retch I had a
vision of an Iraqi man I knew who had no
fingernails and then it goes on at
length about this man who used to come
into your office in Iraq who had been
tortured and all his fingernails taken
off and and how every time you saw your
baby and it's incredible and you like
you started saying you met these people
stayed close to them and wrote horrific
things so what draws you
I mean Syria right now is just about the
most dangerous place on earth we've all
lost friends there are you gonna go back
today well I feel very committed to it
and I also feel that last week after
alkyds hospital was bombed the the
attacks on medical workers I find
absolutely horrific and so I feel the
need and it's not a pull it's
interesting because I do have friends
who I would say are addicted to war and
they clearly are addicted they like the
adrenaline they like the fact that
they're taken out of their ordinary
boring day-to-day lives where we have to
pay bills and drive kids to school and
they go into a war zone where you very
much live in the moment because you're
trying to stay alive but I don't think I
was ever like that I think for me it was
much more about something Martha
Gellhorn said many years ago which was
you have one war that you fall in love
with the rest is responsibility and I
think again Bosnia did that to me and
and now Syria I've fallen in love again
and I do feel very committed to it in
the way that the people I've spent so
much time with and a lot of what I do is
I write about human rights violations so
rape and torture which is very hard to
report and the only way you could do it
is by spending huge amounts of time with
people and gaining their trust you can't
just fly in you know get a quick story
and get out you need to sit on the floor
with them for weeks sometimes I've spent
months in in Kosovo working with just
one village of women an entire village
that had been raped and I worked
actually with Human Rights Watch so it
was we did a very kind of quantitative
research and gathering data and it's
heartbreaking it's I once learned in a
first-aid class that if someone ever
gets hit by shrapnel you can't pull the
the piece of whatever it is out of their
body because they'll bleed to death you
have to staunch it and sustain it and I
feel often when I'm interviewing someone
who's been deeply deeply traumatized you
can't just go in and pull things out of
them you just have just sit and you wait
and you listen and gradually the story
emerges or it might not they might not
want to talk to you um and we're just
saying this story that we wrote about
the girls in Cleveland who had been held
in the basement for ten years it took a
year before the youngest one would start
talking you just need patience
so we're I'm sorry we're you're gonna go
to the audience for some questions and
then I I do want you to if anybody has
quit they can raise their hand and we
have a mic out there if anybody we have
someone here in the front Stan good
evening you mentioned earlier Janeane
and others are referred to it that
reaction to your stories and the change
that it could affect or not in Bosnia it
tooks revenues afore it forced the world
to act and has there been is that what
it takes a huge incident like that or is
the reporting being exist ignored until
that moment occurs the consequences
intended or not a reporting it's a good
question either intended or not which
such humanitarian intervention anymore
we lived in Bosnia and Rwanda were more
the times of humanitarian intervention
and it was much more a time of empathy
and compassion I mean I think we have a
very different administration right now
that um and I think most of us do right
to affect policy in some way I mean that
that's our role essentially is to shine
a light in the darkest corners but
whether or not we can do it and whether
or not we can reach policymakers is is
kind of beyond beyond us but ultimately
that's our goal to get resolutions made
in international law to be honored and
transitional justice to happen and
accountability I mean that's the main
thing I work for I don't want these guys
that rape and torture and kill and
murder to go to have impunity I want
them to pay I want them to end up in in
seeking or getting justice served to
them so I think that's the real reason
it's not always doing here towards
policymakers but like in Vietnam which
is the classic example it was geared
towards telling the public what was
happen
on the ground but an enormous role that
more corresponds have is to let you know
even if Capitol Hill or policymakers not
listening that the public is I think one
of the problems now is we've had so many
wars over the last few years of Iraq
Afghanistan Syria Libya people were be
inured to all of this you know it's
difficult to actually shock people
anymore and I think people were tired of
it all and you know wish it would all go
away frankly Afghanistan in the UK gets
almost no coverage now because I think
people newspapers are battling because
there's so many Wars going on and it's
also become much more dangerous to cover
them I mean that there's two big changes
since I started out one is the
technology which has made it a lot
easier so that we can file from stories
from the top of a mountain or the middle
of a desert when I started out I've kind
of stunned didn't even have a telephone
system so I was going into Afghanistan
for weeks and only being able to call
back my stories when I went back to
Pakistan even then there was no direct
dialing there was telex if you remember
that or I was dictating to copy takers
in London which is quite a difficult
thing to do because you're dictating a
long story and you've got someone at the
other end saying to you is there much
more of this but so that sites become a
lot easier the technology the other side
that's become much harder is that we've
it's become much more dangerous we've
become targets in a way we weren't when
I started out and we find it very
frustrating that there aren't places
that we can't go to and report from
because it's been become so dangerous
and that it's something I never thought
I would say 10 or 20 years ago I just
can't go there because it's too
dangerous has changed so much you know
in the last 10 or 15 years you know as
we've been going through these wars and
there's just so much information out
there and it's not like people feel
they have to read the entire Washington
Post or the New York Times or The Sunday
Times to get their news they pick and
choose what they want to read so a lot
of times you even have stories that are
out there yeah I remember when there was
a controversy or there were bombings on
days and like you Europe and in Pakistan
at the same time and there was people
complaining that you know no one was
covering the Pakistani bomb bombings the
same way they were covering the ones in
Europe and it turns out like somebody's
studied readership of the stories that
were actually done and nobody read those
stories that were done about the
bombings in Pakistan because people
don't care you know and that's I think
the biggest challenge that we face right
now is that everybody only wants to read
stories that reinforce their own
political beliefs and that cover areas
that interest them and the way that the
newspapers used to be and we're never
gonna go back there is you would read
everything you know except for the woman
in the front row who reads everything hi
sorry I actually lived in Syria from
2009 to 2011 so Jeanine my question is
in particular for you but I'm interested
in I'm sorry okay should I repeat what I
was saying or okay I'm a writer and
editor and I actually lived in Syria
from 2009 to 2011 and I was interested
and I visited Bosnia as well and I was
interested if you could talk a little
bit more about the public's reaction to
what was going on to Bosnia at the time
and if you see the reaction now more as
a product of sort of latent Orientalism
or latent racism and if this or if this
was a matter more of geographic distance
and you know that just that kind of
separation and then equally what Syria
can learn from post-war Bosnia I won't
call it post peace Bosnia but in looking
ahead to a transition state what kind of
lessons can we learn from that so two
really really good questions okay I'll
try
the first one when I was reporting
Sarajevo I worked for the Sunday Times
which at that point I was battling
against Princess Diana and Prince
Charles to get in the paper seriously
and I had this horrible foreign editor
who
like took a you know just he he just
said people are bored by this people are
bored by this and it came to one point
where do you remember Romeo and Juliet
in Bosnia the couple a Muslim and a Serb
who ran away to get married and were
killed on a bridge and he wasn't
interested because Princess Diana had
done something and didn't run the story
and then of course it became the icon of
Sarajevo so it was a real struggle and
it was very frustrating but I think we
just felt like we're gonna keep going
we're gonna keep pushing it and what I
would do is they would send me from
London and they'd say you're gonna go
for six weeks and I wouldn't come home
and in those days there weren't cell
phones so they couldn't find me and I
would just disappear and go off and
investigate it go towards Foggia and
investigate the rape camps but it was
hugely frustrating your question about
racism is so interesting because while
Bosnia was happening and we were we felt
that we were being ignored
even though Sarajevo if there were
flights was only three hours from London
by plane the Rwandan genocide was
breaking out in 1994 by the time my
foreign dust sent me there it was May it
had started in April and I think that
one of the reasons that there was that
that it was not not only covered
properly but that the genocide was
allowed to continue was because there
were so few journalists there who could
then get there I think that had they
been there I don't think a million
people would have been killed I think in
some way it could have been halted
lessons learned we should talk after the
event because I have a whole I just
wrote a thesis for the Fletcher School
about the lessons learned from Bosnia on
to the Syrian war I mean mainly let's
hope and pray they don't partition Syria
because we see what a disaster
Bosnia is now 25 years after date and it
stopped the killing but it it's
contributed to the rise of nationalism
sectarianism that never existed before
and I don't want to see that happen to
Syria but we can talk after
I guess my question is um how do you get
to see in a war what you want to see
because the fact is that there was just
a bunch of reporters in Assyria on like
a government tour and it wasn't
dangerous for them at all but I guess
like how do you get to see both sides in
a war without subjecting yourself to
like huge personal risk I think you you
know you are only ever seeing a fragment
of what's going on
you can't ever see the war in general
like I was saying Afghanistan years ago
when you went for weeks and weeks when
you came back to write a story you were
pretty well informed them these days
because if technology were expected to
write immediately and report and so you
can only really genuinely report on
where you are at that particular time
you don't know what's going on elsewhere
and in fact during the war in Iraq when
I came back I was in southern Iraq and
then went to Baghdad and I felt like I'd
missed some of the war by being there
because everyone that watched it at home
had seen all these things on TV and
we're talking about all this stuff and I
know anything about it so and I think
you know it's dangerous when journalists
on the spot try and generalize about
places when actually they they can't see
much more than what they're seeing
there's a big debate about sort of
embedding with troops and you know
whether that's the right thing to do and
I used to be against doing that because
I thought you should go as an
independent and the war in Iraq I was
there as what we record unit laterals
where you weren't attached to anybody
but actually you know that reporting on
your country's troops and what they're
doing is part of the story and I think
the important thing is to try and do
both sides same with Syria if you can go
with the regime and see what they're
showing but you can also go
independently and into rebel-held areas
or other areas then you're getting a
much more balanced picture it's
difficult to do that often countries
don't let you go in if they know that
you've reported with the the fighters
about embedding you embedded yeah I I
embedded I mean I feel the same way that
Christina did I does now but I always
like I hadn't done the unilateral stuff
before and I didn't go on very many
embezzling like that over the five years
I lived over there I mean a week or two
but you know I found like you know I I
realized pretty quickly when I went out
on one embed and this guy said to me you
know at night be sure to take your
photographer with you
photographers by the way love it when
you say your photographer because it
implies like they're your pet but so
they say you know be sure to take your
photographer with you when you go to the
bathroom at night because there are only
three women on the base and I just you
know I said well you're not going to
send me anywhere are you if you think
that I'm gonna face an issue on the base
going to the bathroom at night and I
found a lot of times and I talked to a
lot of folks in the military about this
like when I would hang around them
longer do you send women out on the more
dangerous like missions would you send
me out to corn golf which was the most
dangerous area at that point and they
just sort of said you know we might send
you there but we wouldn't send you on
the more dangerous patrols because we
worried that you know and it's largely
men who are in the military will want to
protect you as opposed to like you know
the male reporters or photographers they
sort of feel like you know they're it's
it's up to them if they're gonna go so I
could see his point so I think that like
when I went out on em beds I got stories
of these guys who would tell me about
broken marriages about the fact that
they hadn't seen their kids and so long
about more like what it was like to have
these constant deployments and then of
course I wrote a story that after the
story where guys kept telling me that
they were not locked and loaded
you know they ended up getting moved to
another more dangerous place because of
what they had told me and you know the
main guy in my story ended up like
getting blown up in an ie D explosion
and losing his leg and I didn't find
that out until after I came back and I
wonder if I'd known about that when I
was over there if it would have made me
pull my punches more on em beds because
I think that is a danger when you're on
an embed that you're going to do stories
that you want the troops to like because
you're with them so much and so when I
was there I always tried to make sure
that I just I'm going to do this story
that I see here I'm not going to worry
about whether anybody likes me
afterwards and I can't deny that when I
found that out after I came back that I
felt really horrible obviously even
though you know so what do you do about
that you know the consequences of
reporting I mean how do you deal with
that it's going particularly about Syria
which Damascus I mean to get visas to
the regime side which the New York Times
just did it's it's actually to be honest
I've initially in the beginning of the
war I got five or six it's really
paranoid making it's not dangerous the
way it is to go on the other side
through Turkey or through Lebanon with
the opposition but you are incredibly
paranoid and when you're when you're
with government minders or especially
Syria whenever you work in a regime or I
was just in Iran or even I was in Egypt
last week there's a different kind of
danger and that is that you're going to
be taken away and put in prison and or
or killed in a place where security
services have absolutely no qualms about
taking foreigners like the Italian
student who was just killed in Egypt and
killing you you do you you're not in
danger of bombs and sniping but it's
quite spooky I mean I've been probably
the most spooked I've been in a long
time in Damascus knowing that I was
being bugged and followed and every
email was being read it's very unnerving
Janeane does a smart thing I thought a
very clever part of the book when when
she talks about taking $100 taxi ride
from Beirut to Damascus kind of just to
set it in the readers mind that it is
pretty close and yet you cross the
border and everything changes and it
gets pretty dangerous pretty quickly and
yet it's right there in the center
different kind of dangerous then I think
all three of these books I mean it is
amazing where Christina talks about all
these people that are in the news you
know Christine is basically interviewed
every single one of them as all of you
guys have and they have this wonderful
personal touch and you know the way you
describe things and also to put yourself
in and Kim Kim's genius you know she's
talking about boyfriends calling and
she's like you know I'd rather go to
Afghanistan you didn't name that guy but
how did he take that I mean the guy did
you name him volt last name I didn't put
his last name and I gave no oh he was I
mean like we're still friends I mean I
got buy-in from everybody who was in the
book they got what I was doing I'm
supposed to come off unlikable in point
points and I'm supposed to be the foil
for America going into this country that
it knew nothing about I'm supposed to
come off as naive and arrogant and just
like America does and you know Farooq is
supposed to be Afghanistan who's like in
it in the beginning but at the certain
point gives a sense that I'm gonna leave
and so it's going to get as much money
as he can you know who could blame them
Jim you you brought up Joseph Heller
before and there's a scene in catch-22
when the pilots are talking to each
other and one of them says I want to
have a long life and the other one asks
why and the answer is well what else is
there I imagine that the three of you
know full well what else is there that
that there's no guarantee for a long
life so for the three of you whether for
that for that risk or for frankly the
apathy of your readers your app or your
editors have you ever thought about
stopping you ever thought about no this
isn't worth it anymore that there's
something else to do or know how you
just kept going
thanks I mean I stopped I might go back
I mean I could see going back and I feel
like every day I make the choice to stay
here and it's a difficult choice to make
because I miss being in Afghanistan I
miss being in Pakistan I miss living in
the middle of the story and having
conversations at night that are
the future of countries and feeling like
you're actually seeing a country change
and watching a democracy get built
I missed that feeling but you know I
decided to see if I could live normal I
mean as normal as any journalist is and
I I'm a metro reporter now in New York
you know then that's what I do and we'll
see how long that lasts but for right
now it's working one of the sort of
arguments in my book is we don't know
how to end wars anymore I wish I've got
a stern word and so I could kind of go
there on holiday with my son I wish
Libya and Iraq and the other places that
God would and you asked if I'd ever
thought of stopping well when I had my
son in 99 I did think I was going to
stop doing what I was doing I write
books other kind of books as well as
this war book and I so I thought I would
stop I had six months off from my
newspaper to research a book and my
husband's Portuguese and we moved to
Portugal the day before September 11th
for me to start writing this book and
the first day that I started writing was
September 11th I got a phone call and I
often wonder if it hadn't been
Afghanistan where bin Laden was would I
have gone back if it'd been Iraq or
somewhere which I didn't have the same
kind of background in but Afghanistan
because it was my first story and I
cared so much about it was almost like
sort of your first love affair I think
and there was no way I wasn't going to
go back and also I'd been angry that
people had forgotten about it after the
Russians left so there was no no thought
of not doing it
being every day and and what else I
could do and one thing I did do is in
2014 I went to work for the UN for a
year because I've spent my entire career
criticizing and going after the UN and
taking them to pieces and I just thought
I wanted to work for the UN refugee
agency which is probably of all of them
the best the best of the lot on the
Syria crisis I wanted to see from that
perspective and I also wanted to gain
more insight into going deeper with
research and the year after that I was
given a fellowship from the Fletcher
School of Law and Diplomacy to do
another degree in international law and
I did that because I just feel like if
I'm going to spend my life researching
human rights I really need to have a
basis in law in which I had gained from
the field but I need it to go deeper and
I just graduated in March and I and I
think all the time you know can I go
work for a bank now can I go can I go
work for Morgan Stanley can I go work
for the British government the French
government the State Department I am no
way addicted to being in the field but I
do feel that we have skills that you
know we've gained over the years that
are important and they're also they're
vital and I think that we we have
something that we need to contribute at
the same time we need to stay alive and
after I was in Grozny when it fell to
Russian forces in 2000 it was the most
closest I've ever come to dying and my
husband at the time said to me the best
journalist is the one who gets out alive
to tell the story and it's true what
we're worth absolutely nothing if we get
killed or if we're maimed so it's it's
that constant
we're not insane we're not crazy we have
a role and I think we do it well and I
think that you know Martha Gellhorn did
it till she was well into her 90s I
don't want to be into my 90's doing it
but I think that you know we we have
there is something we do that's quite
Noble
Janene and I are making it sound like
it's all misery actually you know you
have fun too and that's what Kim really
described so well that you wouldn't keep
going to these places if all it was was
relentless misery a week ago I was at
the most wonderful Kurdish wedding on
the border between Turkey and Syria all
those people there had fled Syria had
terrible stories didn't know when they
would see their home again but they had
fun that night they really made a lot of
effort to enjoy the wedding to show
their children that Kurdish dancing and
music you know you could forget just for
a few hours the misery of what was
happening to their home just you know
less than an hour's drive away and I
think one of the wid is things that ever
happen to me which brought this home to
me after Benazir was killed in Pakistan
she was a good friend of mine and I
thought how is Pakistan gonna survive
this and there was kind of riots in her
home province of Sindh and people talks
about Pakistan breaking up and all of
this sort of apocalyptic stuff and I
arrived at the airport and got taxi
driver and journalist notoriously always
asked the taxi driver what's going on
and they and he said oh it's very grim
everything's very bad so I said yeah you
know Venice is death and everything and
he said to me no we have no discos and I
said what and he said to me we don't
have any discos in Pakistan you know I
was fourteen years of foreign
correspondent and it's so true what they
say it's all about high highs and low
lows and when you come back after all
these high highs you kind of forget the
low lows and and for you guys who and
even myself we've we've lost colleagues
and and gotten killed I mean the lows
are low but the highs are super high and
then at some point you come back and
you're kind of kind of happy to to just
do the middle but it's never like it is
when you're abroad right
they notice that every answer to every
question
[Applause]
you to really exemplify that camaraderie
and and that sisters-in-arms
mentality that I think exists when one
works overseas because there are still
very few of us women in the field doing
this kind of work and so I think it is
very important that we stick up for each
other and that we that there is
solidarity between us and I was a bit
surprised by Jeanine saying at the
beginning that she didn't find that
because I have always found other women
and I think you know the most upsetting
thing as a woman correspondent as a
mother is when other women attack you
for what you do because it isn't easy I
[Music]
am now because I wasn't mentored because
there weren't older women that supported
me and my you know in now I have interns
all the time I have young women I try to
to make them you know I would never say
to someone all the time young people say
to me is it worth becoming a journalist
I think yes absolutely it's the greatest
job in the world so I do I do think
there's solidarity absolutely watch the
movie you know and friends of mine
before the movie was coming out they're
saying hey is that is that Tania
Vanderpool Marc Marc Margot Robbie's
character is that based on me and I said
no because you're not that pretty and
also you're nice you know and because
it's like we just had this group of
people and some of them are in the
audience actually who all just helped
each other and you know we would always
make sure that everybody was taken care
of you talk about stories I just felt no
sort I mean I would have done anything
and I'd still do anything to help the
you know female reporters I worked with
over there and what's nice is like when
you have that you're sort of in this
you're sort of you can call it the kebab
well you can call it whatever but you're
in the sort of zone where you will be
friends for life and you know we didn't
even we barely met each other over there
but like I think that we've like we've
got all the similar sort of she was
saying answers them I guess what I
usually say you know so but also between
different news organizations in
dangerous places people really do bond
together and it's a great question about
solidarity because when you're out there
you you do you know in a way normally
and that especially in this town that
there's a lot of competition it in many
ways that disappears wouldn't you
all right one last question then we can
stay and talk well thank you I'm not
entirely sure how to ask this question
but I want to follow up on a couple of
points that you made you said white why
are we not paying more attention to
what's going on in Aleppo and you said
that we're really in Europe so much of
this conflict now that it just kind of
rolls off of us and and it really kind
of does and one of the reasons I was
really looking forward tonight I figured
collectively your experiences are
amazing and they are but you know for
those of us that are trying to keep up
there are so many different players and
there's so many different conflicts and
all and then the the the external
players Russia the United States here at
Saudi Arabia it all seems pretty
hopeless and and so I'm just curious I
mean you know you said the highs and the
highs and the lows and the lows you know
where is there hope for all of this to
to somehow rather get sorted out or what
is your sense of this it is it's
incredibly complicated and don't feel
ignorant because I mean I literally have
to and I've studied the Middle East for
25 years you know to sit down and draw
graphs and put markers and try to put
things on maps and identify who's
fighting who there's a thousand militias
fighting on the opposition on the Syrian
opposition right now and that's not even
taking into the the international
players you know Russia Russia Qatar
Saudi Iran Turkey Egypt goes on and on
the US all I could say is that you know
wars do end they eventually do end when
when the battle when the players on the
battlefield become exhausted and at this
stage now it's it's gearing up I mean I
don't think Syria is going to go into a
17-year war like Lebanon I do think that
it will eventually come to a head in one
way or another I just wish it would be
sooner rather than later and we don't
have to wait for it to be 400,000 people
dead because that's what your question
earlier about Schreber Nitze in 1992 we
started calling out for it and and we
had to wait until the end of 1995 when
8,000 men and boys were killed so I
don't think we want to wait until
there's a genocide
and and I think that you know President
Obama made a decision a very tactical
decision in 2013 that he did not want to
get engaged in a third Middle Eastern
war because he was elected on a platform
to get out of Wars and doing that policy
of nonchalance has had a great cost and
that was the rise of Isis they didn't
come out of nowhere they've been around
and it's you know it's the result of the
failure in Iraq and it's the result of
our own policy of not paying enough
attention if I saw Isis on the ground in
2012 why was everyone why was the world
so surprised when Mosul finally fell so
I think in some way we we have to have
accountability as well because we're we
allowed our compassion to become
fatigued and that's always a very very
dangerous thing for us to become
complacent and I think that's why I
write what I do is I really want people
to be upset I want them to be shook up
it's not easy to read but it's it's the
truth and I think it's important that
that we digest it being in short term
decisions we care about what's happening
now so actually you can track Isis back
to the jihad in Afghanistan against the
Russians when all-out focus was
defeating the Russians in the Cold War
and we didn't care how we did it so we
brought people from Arab countries who
were criminals or gangsters or Salafists
and encouraged them to come and fight
because our only interest was defeating
the Russians and I think that's one of
the things I find hardest in the job
that you keep seeing the same mistakes
being made over and over again and you
kind of feel like don't we ever learn
look at Afghanistan Iraq Libya every
single one the easy thing is removing
the regime that's not difficult without
militaries but what do you do then and
in each one we haven't had a plan for
what to do afterwards so but just to go
back to your question you know it is
really complicated and it's so
complicated we're on the same site as
some countries in one place and on
in science to them in other places but
the reason I keep doing this is that
where you find hope is in the people I'm
endlessly amazed at how people in the
midst of all these difficult situations
still keep really focused on in
particular trying to educate their
children and I was lucky enough to work
with Malala on her book and you know she
is so inspiring she risked her life to
be able to go to school and for the sake
of other children to go to school and
when you meet people like that and you
can tell their story it makes it all
worth it last word Kim I mean I don't
think I could do this job if I didn't
feel hope right even for Afghanistan and
I'll give it an entire hour speech about
how things are going horribly in
Afghanistan and somebody will say well
then what should we shouldn't we just
pull everybody home and I know you've
got the wrong point I mean I still I
feel like you know what you were saying
is exactly the same sort of things like
we do have a chance there and there have
been improvements there just the very
fact of having cell phone coverage now
in Afghanistan of having the Internet
there of having TV stations like Tolo
there that do reality TV shows where
Afghan women now feel so empowered that
they will do presentations in with their
hair and rock out I mean this one woman
on International Women's Day on you know
Afghan star I watched her performance
and I was like you are the bravest
feminist I've ever seen
so there are positive things happening
there and I think that you try to hold
on to those and the whole idea that if
we just walk away now and we don't
actually give the country stability
enough for the next generation to take
over it would be the biggest mistake and
also look you know it's today we're
looking around saying the world is
falling apart the world is falling apart
look at 30 years ago look at 60 years
ago you can go back through generations
World War two was no picnic so you know
we just happen to know more about it now
because of the internet because of all
the news so I guess I would just say you
know there is hope in every place you're
looking at well you know there's a it's
a long important and complicated
discussion about where America and
Britain and
on the western world goes with Syria
what their obligations are and in
Afghanistan Pakistan but tonight I
thought it was a very special night to
talk to three women who you know kind of
a look behind the news and the people
you guys have done an amazing job with
these three books and as Jeanine says
you know writing to shake things up
their book shake things up their stories
and I'm grateful that tonight you kind
of helped us know who you are a little
bit and kind of why you do what you do
and thank you
[Applause]
[Music]